we're back we're in tokyo we're worth of
japan part dua is dua two in any
language it's french
you combined two and three you know how
you know we're in tokyo the tokyo tower
and the sound of cicadas
we had to bring it along our friend
translator tasty producer lovely person
all around riya mclenny hi we're gonna
be eating things that come on rice in
the shower we may even put on some fancy
clothing which we've never done for a
restaurant before we're doing sushi
let's go how'd he say let's go
today i'm worth it we're gonna be trying
three excellent sushi places at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
at its price and we made the mistake of
coming in 95 degree heat love it i'm
super excited the first place we're
going to is in highly automated sushi
restaurant called kuro sushi we call it
kaiten zushi taitang is like spin sushi
is brought out to you on a conveyor belt
i wish i could be conveyor belted to
this restaurant right now give me a try
yeah conveyor belt me all right
bye
it's like yoshi
[Music]
what are the advantages to having the
automated systems in the restaurant
so
so excited wow of these plates is 100
yen approximately one us dollar so we
have self-service green tea here never
seen something so excited for hot water
hot running water yeah at your table
come on sometimes my shower doesn't even
do that come by
hot
this is the optimal time it's like
enough time for you to look at it and
decide if you want it but then it's like
if you don't get it you're not going to
get it it's like the tinder of dining
yes swipe
maybe we should just go for it pop it
open pop it first hit here we go oh yeah
cheers stephen
perfect oh now i'm excited now i want to
grab hey how about some tuna
i love tuna look at this long cut of
tuna
[Music]
cheers it up
that's so great yeah we can have as many
as we want they just keep coming oh
you've ever been in a lazy river yes oh
my god this is the lazy river oh my god
food but instead of you in the river the
food is in the river you just seize the
river summer it's a pike mackerel
the fish was tender the rice was well
packed like satisfactory in all of the
ways that you want sushi to be what is
this if you get five plates we get to
play the game
oh no no
what happens you lost oh
so if we won what would happen you get
that toy in a in a plastic and then i
want dessert
next
oh fluffy ice with green tea red bean
nice the order was hurt thank you bird
oh here it is
cheers
mmm that's what you need when it's hot
outside
oh yeah ice blast we're at eight plate
count nine
i touched it okay we're at the baseball
stadium i like it yeah get toned
oh
we won't really yeah no way
it's coming out
got some stickers so thank you for the
meal gochiso
that was wonderful fun and cheap yeah
and very
technologically advanced do i appreciate
it so we're headed to our next sushi
spot but before we do that we asked rea
for a suggestion on any desserts that
would look fish-shaped from here here we
are here we go i love it it's a
beautiful stand
we are eating taiyaki the fishy pancake
what do you want i want a red bean
anyone's matcha you can have the macho
one annie
oh it's so cute
i got the red bean it's a green tea hey
all right we're gonna
try this taiyaki now
okay
i also have red bean all right let's
fish cheers
in the 1980s norway had too much salmon
and so there was a guy who was tasked by
the norwegian government to sell some of
it to japan he was able to strike a deal
with a company called nishiren that
catapulted salmon into the sushi market
in japan we didn't have salmon sushi
before that that is a great
international co-lab to bring a new
all-star food into prominence when you
eat fish-shaped food do you eat from the
head or a bottom head bed
head are we going next andrew so next
we're on our way to a place called shun
sushi is that right from here and it
comes recommended by one of our
colleagues named uh hitomi actually my
wife your work life yeah so this
restaurant is neighborhood so she joined
somewhere you want to go once in a while
when you are craving sushi sushi chef
knows you oh that's what i want yeah i
want my suitcase you have to know me how
do you get a work wife you have a work
wife
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
yes absolutely
[Music]
so what are we coming first really
sucking ah
yes
do we shot this or
no we just stood up
he's grating wasabi you know what i love
about sushi you're seeing everything
that goes into
what your money is going to so this is
true here we go first bite
cure and utter
joy you know it's not like a piece of
fish on top of some rice it tastes like
a single unit yeah
foreign
that was delicious
i'm so happy very pleasant texture it's
also really interesting the temperature
that it arrives sushi i don't think is a
cold food it becomes a part of your
mouth
is
[Music]
yeah
it's kind of light what did you do to
the uuni
it tastes like melon
[Music]
the squid
in a word
it was
squidward
what what do you think is the special
elements about a sushi dinner like this
like us sitting here
wow
all raw
oh my gosh
oh yeah
annie's face just perked up egg comes
out and she's like
wow
[Music]
it was almost like biting into a crepe
cake
yes i saved it for annie
samagoyaki
we really appreciate it so thank you
very much
sushi it ended too soon
i love it it was very like comfortable
chef was very friendly and i love the
conversation i realized today i want a
sushi chef like i want a hairstylist my
hair stylist is the person i see
probably more regularly than anybody
else in my life i want that for our
sushi chef yeah this is my sushi dance
i've decided
what part aid sushi we're going to our
final sushi spot the place is called
kyubey and from what i understand we
need to get a little bit fancy riye
what's going on here
it's three michelin star sushi everyone
knows cube the chef from shoe notes my
dad's now it's very famous all right
let's go get that cube
oh
the reason we're dressed up is because
we're eating in a restaurant with a
dress code i
cannot believe that we got such a
prestigious sushi restaurant in tokyo
let's do it
[Music]
cube
[Music]
everybody we've talked to in japan says
is amazing why do you think cupe is so
popular here
[Music]
this has got to be one of the
i don't even know how to talk let's just
eat the greatest opportunities we've had
on this show yeah i'm a little nervous
and this is the top tool to grind this
is shark skin oh wow wow we touch it
here real shark skin oh
arigatou gozaimasu
this is one hundred it's okay
too polite
um
this is thai snapper why does he tap it
with a knife
[Music]
um
[Music]
you're not strong enough andrew i'm
scared don't chill
[Music]
i feel it now
very good yeah
oh wow there's green onion underneath
i'm so excited what is this fish this is
a tuba a turbo turbo tub
and touch top top the sushi this side
this wow bottom and the fish wow softly
softly and you you have yeah
really amazing yeah springiness you try
the
next layer to pick up with a finger okay
okay some and the center finger you're
gonna eat that
he keeps those live shrimp in the same
temperature as the sea water slightly
warm rice with cold shrimp so the soup
finger
oh
[Music]
are you kidding me
your father invented this style yes they
make what in ohio
please
see the drawing i want to hear the
crispy knowledge of the seaweed
that was incredible tasting that was
everything cold cooney the wasabi burn
the warm rice the crunchy seaweed
yeah yes
there i would have thought that that was
like hundreds of years old that style
called the gunkan maki gun kong is a
battle ship
yeah
i love that battle ships because they
kind of look like battleship that's my
favorite should get some more sake no
would you like some adam adam's a sucker
for good glasses adam took a sip of the
sake and said i just realized how all
sake was supposed to taste for the first
time
yeah for sure
i think he want to utilize all the
ingredients the real head to tail
it's like a little shrimp chip
eel
wow
wow
it's so beautiful
oh wow that was really new tasting for
me because i've had a lot of sardines
before but never like this baby taste
yeah i was expecting more of a fishier
taste sushi
[Music]
wow it's so custard it's like flan
and then adam died
oh my gosh
wow
what a hospitality usually when i put on
my suit i have to go somewhere i'm
thinking what is this night going to
bring me but having a great day
oh
a baloney
wow having a great time feel like i'm
hanging out in somebody's basement you
know just playing video games i feel
like i stepped in something oh yeah i
can never go back the thing that was
every piece kind of had like its own
kick about it or its own character its
own personality
this is it
have your question i do i have one
question why is sushi so great
[Music]
i'll never forget it
guys i want to say you all look snazzy
today adam especially you don't look too
bad yourself there thank you very much
doesn't change the fact that we have to
do our jobs and our job today is which
sushi restaurant what's the most worth
it to you at its price i truly loved
every place we went to although at first
glance a lot of the preparations might
look the same you really got a
completely different thing at every
restaurant i think each would be worth
going to at their price point for me if
i came back to tokyo i would go to cuba
i think it's that good it would be worth
the price every time uh really i like
this episode a lot because like sushi is
something special like in japan and you
can enjoy different levels my worst late
winner is cuba oh
i knew it it's also not too expensive
you could spend a lot more at a
restaurant yeah i wanted soon to be my
winner because it was like my barber of
sushi but i do also have to go cube he
paid attention to every detail annie
wow adam
cube
that's it for uh sushi quick shout out
to daiki when it's coming from tasty
japan who helped us get into kyubey
we're still in japan we got one more
episode here it's rye's favorite food
gonna be visiting a very special old
friend next week on worth it
he noticed you were left-handed right
away have you ever felt so noticed no i
didn't feel noticed when i went into
seventh grade and all the chairs were
built for right-handed people so he's
better than chair manufacturers that's
for sure oh yes